This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证是真人。嘿，大家近来如何？欢迎收听《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个节目聚焦于黑人男性的生活经历，进行在其他任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起探讨。有多少男人带着盔甲生活？它向世界释放出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须要这么做，请收听
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
《艰难成长的教训》，可在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能锻炼，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。名字就是数字2%，可在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
请收听《相信我，宝贝，闺蜜会保护你》（The Girlfriends. Trust Me, Babe），可在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回首往事》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格lish（Alex English）。在每一集里，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是怎么熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is great to have you here. Before we get into it, I just want to say a huge big thank you to everyone who has already subscribed to my Patreon in the last week. If you don't know, we officially launched the psychology. of your 20s Patreon.
和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。1984年真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请收听《回首往事》（Look Back at It），可在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里。在我们深入正题之前，我只想对过去一周已经订阅我Patreon的所有人表达巨大的感谢。如果你还不知道，我们正式上线了“20多岁的心理学”
This podcast is really just me. I write all the scripts. I do all the editing. I put out two episodes every week. And a lot of work goes into that, a lot of behind the scenes action. So I thought I would give you guys an opportunity to kind of peek behind the microphone,
（The Psychology of Your 20s）的Patreon。这个播客实际上只有我一个人。我写了所有的脚本。我包办了所有的剪辑。我每周发布两集节目。这其中投入了大量的工作，有很多幕后运作。所以我想给你们大家一个机会，一窥麦克风背后、
peek behind the curtain, and see some of that process. You get access to bonus episodes, to a newsletter, to the episode transcripts, you get a vote on what episodes come out next and exclusive access to merchandise, to updates, all of those wonderful things. So if you haven't already checked it out, please feel free to look in the episode description and you will find a link to our Patreon. This episode has been on my list for a while as something to discuss on the podcast.
一窥后台幕帘，了解一些这样的制作过程。你可以获得独家播客节目、一份通讯、节目文字稿，你可以对接下来要播出的节目进行投票，还可以独家购买周边产品、获取更新，所有这些美妙的内容。所以如果你还没去看看的话，请随时查看节目简介，你会在那里找到通往我们Patreon的链接。这一期节目已经在我的清单上待了一段时间了，作为要在播客中讨论的主题。
But it's kind of always been pushed down by other more relevant topics, despite being, I think, something really valuable to discuss on a podcast that relates to our 20s and obviously the psychology behind our experiences. It was something in the media recently that has really motivated me to finally sit down and do some deep thinking and research on the topic of gaslighting and also kind of revisit my own knowledge and kind of understanding of the concept. Last week, this incredible pro surfer called Sarah Brady shared this series of DMs from an ex-boyfriend
但它不知为何总是被其他更相关的话题推后，尽管我认为这是一个非常值得在与我们20多岁以及我们的经历背后的心理学相关的播客中讨论的话题。最近媒体上发生的一件事真正激励了我，让我终于坐下来对煤气灯效应（gaslighting）这个话题进行了深入思考和研究，并重新温习了我对这一概念的知识和理解。上周，这位出色的职业冲浪运动员萨拉·布拉迪（Sarah Brady）分享了一系列私信，来自她的一位前男友，
of hers who was quite famous and I would say well known and they were genuinely gut churning and awful a very intimate I would say brave look at how gas sliding kind of occurs in an intimate relationship and it really sparked
他相当有名，可以说是家喻户晓，而这些私信内容真让人感到胃里翻江倒海、极其糟糕，这是一个非常私密的、可以说很勇敢的视角，展现了亲密关系中是如何发生煤气灯操纵的，它确实引发了
a lot of online debate and discussion around this idea and its validity and how the term and how the concept of gas-liding is used by people to leverage psychological control over others. It feels like a good time to talk about it and really cover the psychology, the evidence, the research behind what this behavior really means. I think that when terms like these, terms that are very much part of the psychobabble,
关于这个概念及其有效性的大量网络辩论和讨论，以及人们如何利用这个术语和概念来对他人施加心理控制。现在似乎是讨论它的好时机，并且真正探讨这种行为真正意味着什么背后的心理学、证据和研究。我认为，当诸如此类的术语——这些非常属于心理学大杂烩（psychobabble）一部分的术语——
have a bit of a surge in their use in the media, it's also important to clarify what they actually mean. Often their interpretation can be misused and extrapolated to kind of undermine survivors. But I've also found that when they're used frequently in the media, sometimes they lose a bit of sensitivity and they become quite generalized to describe a whole range of behaviors that may not actually fall into this concept and could perhaps be better explained by a different term. I think the example that I gave earlier of this amazing woman, her situation is gas-liding. And yet there has been all this rhetoric around, oh, is that term too used? Have we lost an understanding of what it means? I think having the proper language to explain our experiences
在媒体上的使用出现激增时，澄清它们的实际含义也很重要。通常它们的解释会被误用并被过度推演，从而在某种程度上削弱了幸存者的经历。但我也发现，当它们在媒体中被频繁使用时，有时它们会失去一些敏感性，并变得相当泛化，用来描述一整串可能并不真正属于这个概念的行为，而这些行为或许可以用另一个不同的术语来更好地解释。我认为我刚才举的那位了不起的女性的例子，她的处境就是煤气灯操纵。然而，却充斥着各种言论，比如，这个词是不是被用烂了？我们是不是已经失去了对它含义的理解？我认为拥有正确的语言来解释我们的经历
is so empowering, but also having a strong knowledge base to relate those experience to is also really important. So today, we're going to talk about the psychology of gaslighting. We're going to examine where the concept and the term actually originated and how its meaning has really shifted quite a bit in the last 50 years from its initial use to kind of describe a fairly common practice of convincing women they were going insane to institutionalize them to nowadays a much more nuanced understanding of what emotional abuse, and psychological abuse really is. So we're going to dive into what it looks like, how to identify gaslighting,
是如此具有赋能作用，但拥有一个坚实的知识基础来将这些经历与之联系起来也同样非常重要。所以今天，我们将讨论煤气灯效应的心理学。我们将审视这个概念和术语最初是如何起源的，以及在过去50年里，它的含义是如何从最初用来描述一种相当普遍的做法——即说服女性她们正在发疯以便将她们送进精神病院——转变为如今对情感虐待和心理虐待真正含义的更细致的理解。因此，我们将深入探讨它的表现形式、如何识别煤气灯操纵、
what tactics gasliders use and the links to narcissism, links to manipulation, Machiavellianism. Beyond that, how do people learn to gaslight others? Do they actually consciously know what they're doing? And how does it kind of link to things like group think and stereotypes, in really unexpected ways. There is so much more to this than what we have been told. It's a super serious matter and behavior.
煤气灯操纵者使用什么战术，以及它与自恋、操纵、马基雅维利主义的联系。除此之外，人们是如何学会对他人进行煤气灯操纵的？他们真的有意识地知道自己在做什么吗？以及它与群体思维（groupthink）和刻板印象等事物之间，是如何以意想不到的方式联系在一起的。这里面包含的内涵远比我们被告知的要多得多。这是一个极其严肃的事情和行为。
And I think especially in our 20s, when reality and our self-concept already feel quite shaky, being exposed to this kind of manipulation, can be really impactful and life-altering, not just in romantic situations, but within our families, between friends, even in our workplaces, when we really sit down and examine what gaslighting is, we suddenly become conscious of it in so many types of interactions and relationships.
我认为尤其是在我们20多岁的时候，当现实感和自我概念已经让人感觉相当动摇时，暴露在那种操纵之下，可能会产生真正的重大影响并改变一生，不仅在浪漫关系中，而且在我们的家庭中、朋友之间、甚至在我们的工作场所，当我们真正坐下来审视什么是煤气灯操纵时，我们会突然在如此多的互动和关系类型中意识到它。
It's so much more than just lying or dishonesty. It's a very systematic pattern of behavior used to convince someone that their reality, their perspective, their sanity is all something that needs to be questioned. And I think that it's important we all know about it and understand it from a psychological perspective. And also that we know what to do in the face of gaslighting. It's something that we may be exposed to. So how do we detach from these people? I think this episode is so fascinating, such important general knowledge.
这远不止是说谎或不诚实。这是一种非常系统化的行为模式，用来让人相信他们的现实、他们的视角、他们的理智都是需要受到质疑的东西。我认为我们所有人都了解它并从心理学角度理解它非常重要。而且我们也必须知道在面对煤气灯操纵时该怎么做。这是我们可能会接触到的东西。那么我们该如何与这些人划清界限呢？我认为这一集太迷人了，是如此重要的常识。
And we have so many studies and theories to cover. I'm really keen to get into it and really sink our teeth into what it truly means. So without further ado, let's jump into the episode. Terms like gaslighting have become a massive part of our shared language and dialogue in recent years. And we've really seen a spike in usage and popularity, not just in self-help communities or amongst therapist, but also in the media and in everyday conversations. Some people find that problematic and they link it to the adoption of so-called therapy speak, whereby we use psychological language in terms to describe everyday behaviors. But I think personally and therapy speak aside,
而且我们要涵盖的研究和理论太多了。我真的很想深入探讨，并真正深入挖掘它真正的含义。废话不多说，让我们直接切入本集节目。像煤气灯操纵（gaslighting）这样的词在近年来已经成为我们共同语言和对话的巨大一部分。我们确实看到它的使用频率和受欢迎程度急剧上升，不仅在自助社群中或在治疗师之间，而且在媒体和日常对话中也是如此。有些人觉得这有问题，他们将其与所谓“治疗腔”（therapy speak）的采纳联系起来，即我们使用心理学语言和术语来描述日常行为。但我个人认为，抛开治疗腔不谈，
I do believe that having an accurate knowledge and understanding of terms like gaslighting is really important because it's not like the behavior is new. It's existed for centuries. But unlike previous generations, our generation now has the language to identify the same. specifics and to know what this means and to put a word to it. I think that that really improves the conversations we have around mental health, but also around things like coercive
我确实相信，准确了解和理解像煤气灯操纵这样的术语非常重要，因为这种行为并非新事物。它已经存在了几个世纪。但与前几代人不同的是，我们这一代人现在有了语言来识别这些具体细节，知道这意味着什么，并为其起一个名字。我认为这确实改善了我们围绕心理健康展开的对话，同时也改善了围绕诸如强制控制、
control and abusive relationships and power imbalances. Let's quickly talk through the history of this term before we get into some of the specifics. Contrary to popular belief or maybe general understanding, gaslighting was not a term created by psychics. psychologist or anyone in the medical profession, it actually originated as a pop culture reference from a movie released in the 1940s. And in this movie, it's kind of like the pivotal plot point is this husband who secretly like dims and brightens the light in their home to convince his wife that she's going quote unquote crazy for the purpose of being able to put her in a medical institution and basically steal from her. From there, it slowly become part of our lexicon
虐待关系和权力失衡等事情的对话。在我们进入一些具体细节之前，让我们快速讨论一下这个术语的历史。与大众看法或普遍理解相反，煤气灯操纵并不是由心理学家、精神病学家或医疗行业的任何人创造的术语，它实际上起源于20世纪40年代上映的一部电影中的流行文化梗。在这部电影中，一个关键情节是丈夫暗中调暗和调亮家里的灯光，以此来说服他的妻子她正在“发疯”，其目的是能够将她送进医疗机构，并基本上窃取她的财产。从那以后，它慢慢成为了我们词汇的一部分，
before being adopted by amateur psychology, kind of in like the 1970s and 80s. And it was used almost like as a colloquial reference or a synonym for things like brainwashing in intimate relationships. Similar to its initial depiction in that movie, it was exclusively kind of used to describe instances in which a partner, usually the husband, manipulates their spouse and their spouse is reality or their physical environment to convince them and those around them that they are experiencing some form of psychosis or a mental health condition, the goal of which was to get rid of them essentially for some personal gain. It was describing the manipulation of kind of a broader misunderstanding
然后在20世纪70年代和80年代左右被业余心理学所采纳。它几乎被当作一种通俗的参考或同义词，用来指代亲密关系中的洗脑之类的事情。类似于它在该电影中的最初描绘，它几乎专门用来描述这样一种情况：伴侣（通常是丈夫）操纵他们的配偶以及配偶的现实或物理环境，以说服他们及其周围的人他们正在经历某种形式的精神病或心理健康状况，其最终目标基本上是为了某种个人利益而摆脱他们。它描述的是对更广泛的心理健康误解的操纵，
of mental health and a manipulation of a person's reality to exploit this individual. It obviously, I think, means a lot more than that now, but I do also want to stipulate that when it comes to its use in psychology and psychiatry, although the behavior and the behavioral pattern is very much real and explored in the field, the term gas-siding is still somewhat seen as a bit of a colloquialism. And there's been this debate around, it's overuse and how that has potentially minimized the actual effects of the abuse that it's used to describe. I think some people find it quite frustrating, specifically online, to see very serious terms like gas-siding used to describe behavior that maybe doesn't actually fit the clinical
以及对一个人现实的操纵，以剥削这个个体。我认为它现在的含义显然远不止于此，但我也想说明的是，当谈到它在心理学和精神病学中的使用时，尽管这种行为和行为模式在这一领域非常真实且得到了探讨，“煤气灯操纵”这个词在某种程度上仍然被视为一种口语化的说法。而且一直存在着关于它的过度使用以及这可能如何淡化了它所描述的虐待的实际效果的争论。我认为有些人觉得很沮丧，特别是在网络上，看到诸如煤气灯操纵这样非常严肃的术语被用来描述那些可能并不真正符合临床特征的行为，
profile, like an argument with a friend or a disagreement. But that doesn't mean that the term isn't still really important. It still has immense value and it's regularly discussed in psychological fields. Additionally, we've seen genuine legal change around recognition of gaslighting as a form of emotional abuse or even domestic violence. I actually didn't know this until I was researching this episode, but in countries like the UK, you can be charged. with gaslighting as part of criminal domestic violence laws. And they've charged some 600 people with this offense. So although there is some disciplinary disagreement, I think there's no denying that gaslighting and its impact and its contextual relevance is very much real. And I wanted to just quickly
比如与朋友的争吵或分歧。但这并不意味着这个术语不再重要。它仍然具有巨大的价值，并且在心理学领域经常被讨论。此外，我们在法律上也看到了真正的变革，即承认煤气灯操纵是一种情感虐待甚至家庭暴力形式。我实际上在研究这一集之前并不知道这一点，但在像英国这样的国家，作为刑事家庭暴力法的一部分，你可能会被以煤气灯操纵罪起诉。他们已经指控了大约600人犯有此罪。因此，尽管存在一些学科上的分歧，但我认为无可否认的是，煤气灯操纵及其影响和语境相关性是非常真实的，我只想快速说明这一点，
say that because I know that debate does kind of come up around it. But quick history lesson aside, I think it's valuable to explore what gaslighting is and what gas sliding isn't. Psychologists, they use the term gaslighting to refer to a specific behavioral profile or type of manipulation where the manipulator is trying to get someone else, normally an intimate partner or someone close to them, to question their own reality, to question their memory or perceptions in order to exert control over them for their own benefit. It's a lot more complex than just lying or a disagreement. It is a systematic form of what we would call coercive control that is performed over an extended period of time in a way that really attempts to undermine our sense of sanity and the validity of our experiences.
因为我知道围绕它确实会出现那种争论。但抛开简短的历史课不谈，我认为探讨什么是煤气灯操纵以及什么不是煤气灯操纵是很有价值的。心理学家使用“煤气灯操纵”一词来指代一种特定的行为特征或类型的操纵，其中操纵者试图让其他人——通常是亲密伴侣或亲近的人——去质疑他们自己的现实、质疑他们的记忆或感知，以便为了他们自己的利益而对其实施控制。这比单纯的说谎或意见不合要复杂得多。这是一种我们称之为强制控制的系统化形式，在很长一段时间内持续进行，这种方式真正试图破坏我们的理智感以及我们经历的有效性。
Another way that it's described is kind of as an attempt by the gas slider to replace our reality with their own version, a version that they control in which we cannot trust our own judgment so we begin to rely on them for validation of our circumstances, to validate our emotions, to validate our interpretation of reality. Most of the time it occurs in quite personal or intimate relationships, often romantic, but sometimes with family, friends, even co-workers. And the reason why this form of manipulation occurs on such a personal relational level is because of the nature of the abuse. The main purpose and goal of gaslighting is to manipulate your sense of what is true. And inherent to that is kind of a necessary level of trust in the other person.
另一种对它的描述是，煤气灯操纵者企图用他们自己的版本来取代我们的现实——一个由他们控制的版本，在这个版本中我们无法相信自己的判断，于是我们开始依赖他们来验证我们的处境、验证我们的情绪、验证我们对现实的解读。大多数时候，它发生在相当个人或亲密的关中，通常是浪漫关系，但有时也发生在家庭、朋友甚至同事之间。这种形式的操纵之所以发生在如此个人和关系层面的原因，在于这种虐待的本质。煤气灯操纵的主要目的和目标是操纵你对真实事物的感知。而这其中固有的是对另一个人必不可少的信任水平。
For example, if a stranger was to say, you know, that's not what I did. You're crazy. You're remembering things wrong. We have no reason to trust them. We don't have past experiences with them. We don't have memories with them. So we don't always believe that what they're saying is truthful. That's why it's so insidious because it takes what is so pure about our close relationship with someone, that bond, that willingness to trust them, that sense of security.
例如，如果一个陌生人说，你知道，我没做过那种事。你疯了。你记错了。我们没有理由信任他们。我们与他们没有过去的经历。我们与他们没有共同的记忆。所以我们并不总是相信他们说的是实话。这就是为什么它如此阴险，因为它夺走了我们与某人密切关系的纯粹之处——那种纽带、那种愿意信任他们的意愿、那种安全感。
And it distorts it. It weaponizes it against us. Additionally, I think it's worth saying. it doesn't, you know, start on day one. Often this person, particularly if they're a romantic partner, will build up our bond over time and they make you feel as if you've never known someone as well as you know them, that you guys are soulmates, this relationship is deeply spiritual and supernatural and that they are the only one that you can trust.
然后扭曲它。把它当作武器来对付我们。此外，我认为值得一提的是，它并不是在第一天就开始的。通常这个人，特别是如果他们是浪漫伴侣的话，会随着时间的推移建立起我们之间的纽带，他们会让你觉得你从来没有像了解他们那样了解过任何人，你们是灵魂伴侣，这种关系是深刻的灵性的和超自然的，而且他们是你唯一可以信任的人。
So what does it actually look like? I want to return to Sarah's case here. that woman who shared those messages between herself and her ex that really kind of inspired this episode. In those messages, I don't know if you've read them, I would really advise, go and read up on this, it's super fascinating, but he would repeatedly say things like that she was overreacting in response to his demands. He would ask that she not wear certain clothing, despite that being an insanely excessive demand.
那么它到底长什么样？我想回到萨拉的案子上来。就是那个分享了她与前男友之间那些真正启发了本集节目的信息的女性。在那些信息中，我不知道你们有没有读过，我强烈建议大家去读一读，这超级迷人，但他会反复说一些诸如她在过度应对他的要求之类的话。他会要求她不要穿某些衣服，尽管这是一个极其过分的要求。
He would shift the blame for his reactions onto her, saying that her response were the reason he was acting that way, saying that she was too sensitive, and when she would call out his behaviours, he would repeatedly kind of say that she'd remembered it wrong, that her interpretation wasn't true. And a lot of that fits the profile of how we see gaslighting manifest in relationships. It may start out with seemingly small offences, statements like, yeah, I don't remember it that way, or, you know, you're confusing me, or, you know, you're always overreact, you're so sensitive. Things that I think feel quite easy to overlook. However, once the gas slider can identify that you are questioning your own judgment, that you are questioning reality thanks to their actions, these statements and even their behavior becomes a lot more deliberate and far reaching.
他会把对他的反应的责任推卸到她身上，说她的反应是他那样做的原因，说她太敏感了，而当她指出他的行为时，他会反复说她记错了，她的解读不是真的。这其中有很多都符合我们在关系中看到的煤气灯操纵的表现特征。它可能始于看似微小的冒犯，比如“是的，我不记得是那样了”或者“你知道，你把我搞糊涂了”或者“你知道，你总是反应过度，你太敏感了”之类的话。我觉得这些话很容易被忽视。然而，一旦煤气灯操纵者能够确定你正在因为他们的行动而质疑你自己的判断、质疑现实时，这些言论甚至他们的行为就会变得更加蓄意且影响深远。
the whole purpose is to detach you from your instincts, from your sense of self, from your ability to trust yourself by creating kind of a barrier between your rational mind, your logical mind, and your emotive mind, and making sure that they control both. Conflict in any kind of relationship is normal, but when something causes conflict or causes you to be unhappy or upset, in this situation, the only thing, the other. other person uses this range of tactics to kind of win. They may claim that it simply never happened, you know, an outright denial of reality as we know it. That can be really scary, really terrifying to feel like you are not in control of your mind or you're creating these scenarios that feel
其全部目的在于通过在你的理性思维、逻辑思维和情感思维之间制造某种屏障，并确保他们控制这两者，从而将你从你的直觉、你的自我意识、你信任自己的能力中剥离出来。任何关系中的冲突都是正常的，但当某事引起冲突或导致你不高兴或心烦意乱时，在这种情况下，另一个人会使用这一系列战术来取胜。他们可能会声称这根本没有发生过，你知道，对我们所知的现实进行彻底的否定。这可能真的很吓人，让人觉得你无法掌控自己的思维，或者你正在创造这些感觉真实的情景，
real because they are real, but they're telling you that they're not. And that is so horrific, that belief that you cannot tell what is real and what is real. false because someone you love is convincing you otherwise. I think another typical response is kind of convincing you that you're crazy. I don't like that word, but for lack of a better word, or that you're experiencing some kind of mental health crisis or you're quote unquote hysterical or overreacting. This is particularly common in male, female, romantic relationships, where the male party is gas-sliding the woman. There is this, really fascinating paper titled The Sociology of Gaslighting. It was published in 2019. I'm going to leave it
因为它们确实是真实的，但他们却告诉你它们不是。这太可怕了，那种因为你爱的人说服你相信别的事而分不清什么是真什么是假的想法。我认为另一个典型的回应是说服你“你疯了”。我不喜欢这个词，但在找不到更好词的情况下，或者说你正在经历某种心理健康危机，或者你所谓的“歇斯底里”或反应过度。这在男女浪漫关系中尤其常见，其中男性一方在对女性进行煤气灯操纵。有一篇非常迷人的论文，题为《煤气灯操纵的社会学》（The Sociology of Gaslighting）。它发表于2019年。我将把它留在
in the episode description because it's super fascinating. And it highlights how gaslighting is particularly powerful in dynamics where gender has already kind of created an initial power imbalance. That's because historically, women have always been depicted as irrational and less in control of. And less in control, of their emotions. So male partners who happen to be gasliders are able to leverage these stereotypes for their own gain. You know, we cannot discuss gaslighting without also discussing gender, because as we all know, we live in a society in which gender creates social inequality. And abuse is more commonly initiated by a male partner, not always, but most of the time. and that same kind of trend goes for gas-liding because it is a form of coercion.
节目简介中，因为它超级迷人。它突显了煤气灯操纵在性别已经造成了最初权力失衡的动态关系中是如何特别强大的。这是因为在历史上，女性一直被描绘成不理智的、对情绪的控制力较弱的群体。因此碰巧是煤气灯操纵者的男性伴侣能够利用这些刻板印象来谋取私利。你知道，我们在讨论煤气灯操纵时不可能不讨论性别，因为众所周知，我们生活在一个性别造成社会不平等的社会中。而且虐待更常见由男性伴侣发起，虽然不总是这样，但大多数时候是。同样的趋势也适用于煤气灯操纵，因为它是一种强制形式。
It's a form of psychological abuse. But also, we can even see how gender played a role in the initial conceptualization of this phrase. You know, husbands using tactics to essentially manipulate their wives and have them locked up. The very emergence of the term is rooted in gender inequality. when perpetrators mobilized gender-based stereotypes, structural inequalities, institutional vulnerabilities as well against someone else in an intimate relationship, that's when gaslighting is particularly devastating, especially when they combine that with these kind of made-up concerns
这是一种心理虐待的形式。不仅如此，我们甚至可以看出性别在这个短语最初概念化过程中所扮演的角色。你知道，丈夫们使用战术来本质上操纵他们的妻子并把她们关起来。这个词的出现本身就植根于性别不平等。当施暴者针对亲密关系中的其他人动用基于性别的刻板印象、结构性不平等、机构脆弱性时，煤气灯操纵就会变得特别具有毁灭性，特别是当他们将这些与对某人心理可信度或情绪状态的这种捏造的担忧结合起来时。我认为除了将心理健康问题武器化之外，煤气灯操纵者还可以采取步骤来物理改变我们的现实和周围环境，以进一步使我们的现实和记忆失效。
about someone's psychological trustworthiness or emotional state. I think beyond this weaponization of mental health concerns, a gas lighter can also take steps to physically alter our reality and our surroundings to further invalidate our reality and our memory. I was reading through some case studies of this and I thought these were examples were really interesting to share. One of them was someone, a partner who would hide their spouse's keys or their wallet or their possessions in a different place to where they left them and then berate them that you know you can't find them because you're so disorganized because your memory is so terrible.
我当时在阅读一些关于这方面的案例研究，我认为这些例子非常有趣，值得分享。其中一个是某个人，某个伴侣会把他们配偶的钥匙、钱包或财产藏在他们离开时不同的地方，然后训斥他们，你知道你找不到它们是因为你太无条理了，因为你的记忆力太糟糕了。我看到的另一个案例是从你的手机发送短信然后将其删除，但随后将其作为所谓的证据在稍后证实你对现实的解读是错误的，并且你一定是因为不记得之前的评论而精神失常。我还读过这样一个案例研究，我，就像我读到这个时，它让我，它字面上让我感到胃里翻江倒海。
The other one that I saw was sending text messages from your phone and then deleting them, but using them as so-called evidence later on to confirm that your interpretation of reality is wrong and that you must be insane for not remembering previous comments. I also read this one case study, which I, like I read this, it made my, it literally made me sick to my stomach. It was from a psychologist and she was recounting her client and how her client's husband would steal her birth control pills and convince her that she'd already taken them for the day, effectively undermining her control over her fertility by using gaslighting to convince her
那是一位心理学家在叙述她的客户以及她客户的丈夫如何偷走她的避孕药并说服她她已经吃过当天的那份药，通过使用煤气灯操纵说服她无法相信自己的记忆，从而有效地破坏了她对生育的控制权，因此她不得不依靠他来确认事情。这些个人具体的例子记录得相当充分，我们可以谈论的也有很多，但通常煤气灯操纵的典型模式遵循六种行为特征或模式。了解这些行为是什么，可以帮助我们识别我们是否正在遭受煤气灯操纵，我们在拥有的关系中是否存在这种迹象。这六个特征或六个行为是：隐瞒（withholding）、对抗（countering）、轻视（trivializing）、否认（denial）、转移（diverting）和套用刻板印象（stereotyping）。让我们逐一探讨这六种行为。首先，隐瞒涵盖了隐蔽和明目张胆的说谎，
that she couldn't trust her own memory and therefore she had to rely on him to confirm things. These individual specific examples are quite well documented and there are so many that we could speak on but generally the typical pattern of gas sliding follows six behavioral profiles or patterns. And these behaviors, knowing what these behaviors are, can help us identify if we're being gaslit, if there is some sign of this in a relationship that we have. These six profiles or six behaviors are withholding, countering, trivializing, denial, diverting, and stereotyping. So let's step through each of these one by one. Firstly, withholding covers both insidious and blatant lying,
同时也包括当你试图提出你的担忧时假装听不懂。他们拒绝倾听。他们让你怀疑自己。例如，他们可能会说：“哦，你知道，你太糊涂了”或者“我不知道你在说什么”。或者隐瞒能够让你验证自己情绪或经历的重要信息。其次，我们有对抗。当有人质疑你的记忆时，这就是对抗。他们会说这样的话：“你确定吗？”
but also pretending that they don't understand you when you try and bring up your concerns. They refuse to listen. They make you doubt yourself. For example, they might say, oh, you know, you're so confused or I don't know what you're talking about. Or withholding important information, that would allow you to validate your emotions or your experiences. Secondly, we have countering. This is when someone questions your memory. They say things like, are you sure about that?
“你的记性太差了。你总是忘事。你总是忘记发生了什么。”或者他们会添加一些不正确的额外细节，以此来近乎植入虚假记忆。虚假记忆是我在心理学中最喜欢的话题和理论之一。当我们讨论煤气灯操纵时，它们实际上非常有价值去理解。所以这种虚假记忆的概念，本质上是由于他人的影响，我们对事件的回忆或记忆被扭曲或捏造了。这最初是由伊丽莎白·洛夫图斯（Elizabeth Loftus）在关于犯罪现场证人证词的研究中进行检验的。
You have such a bad memory. You always forget things. You always forget what happened. Or they add additional incorrect details as a way to almost plant false memories. False memories are one of my favorite topics, theories in psychology. They're actually really valuable to understand when we discuss gas lighting. So this idea of false memories, it's essentially that our recollection or our memory of an event is distorted or fabricated due to someone else's influence. So this was first examined by Elizabeth Loftus in regard to witness testimonies about a crime scene.
她发现的是，根据调查人员提出的问题，甚至他们使用的词语（你知道，比如诱导性问题，引导他们得出特定答案），人们对事件的回忆可能会完全不同。从某种意义上说，新的细节是在我们不知情的情况下被植入的。如果我们甚至没有意识到这一点，如果某人——特别是处于权威地位的人，比如我们信任和钦佩的伴侣——是那个告诉我们这些的人，它对我们来说就会感觉很真实。因此，如果一个煤气灯操纵者反复强化事件的某个特定虚假细节，这个细节也许我们不记得了，因为它根本没有发生过，如果这种细节被重复足够多次，我们就会开始相信它。而且我们的最初回忆会被他们的操纵所污染。
And what she found is that depending on the questions asked by the investigator, even what words they were used, you know, kind of leading questions, guiding them to a specific answer. people could remember an event entirely differently. In a sense, new details are planted without our conscious knowledge. And we don't even realize that feels real to us if someone, particularly someone in a position of authority, such as a partner who we trust and who we admire, is the one telling us that. So if a gas slider repeatedly reinforces a specific fake detail of an event, that maybe we don't remember because it didn't happen, if that is repeated enough, we can kind of begin to believe it. And we, our initial recollection is contaminated by their manipulation.
我们开始认为他们知道得更好，他们是通过提醒我们在帮助我们。这绝对不是我们的错。这完全是通过他们的操纵才发生的，这就是为什么即使是那些真正良性的陈述或问题——比如“真的是那样发生的吗？那不是我记忆中的样子”——在这种情况下也可能如此阴险。轻视是需要注意的第三个迹象。当某人贬低或忽视我们的感受并试图削弱我们情绪的真诚度时，就会发生这种情况。他们不尊重我们的反应。他们甚至可能指责我们在面对一个非常
We begin to think that they know better, that they're helping us by reminding us. That is absolutely not our fault. It's entirely through their manipulation that it occurs. and it's why even those really benign statements or questions of, you know, is that what really happened? That's not how I remember it. Can be so insidious in these situations. Trivializing is the third sign to look out for. This occurs when someone kind of belittles or disregards how we feel and attempts to undermine the sincerity of our emotions. They, don't respect our reaction. They may even accuse us of, you know, being too sensitive or overreacting in response to a very
有效且合理的担忧时“过于敏感”或“反应过度”，因为这意味着他们不必认真对待你。你的情绪成了你个人的过失，而不是他们应该关心的事。这也会产生连带效应，让你觉得你无法向他们表达你的感受，你基本上被剥夺了发言权，因为你担心这只会强化他们对你过于敏感或过度反应的看法。他们让你觉得只要表达自己的感受就会受到评判。不过事情是这样的。一个爱你的人、一个关心你的人会关你的情绪，不管它们是如何表达的。
valid and reasonable concern because this means that they don't have to take you seriously. And your emotions are a personal fault rather than something that they should be concerned about. This can also have the run-on effect of making you feel like you can't express your feelings to them and you're essentially being silenced because you're worried that you'll only reinforce their perception of you as overly sensitive or hyperreactive. They make you feel like you're going to be judged for simply expressing how you feel. Here's the thing though. Someone who loves you, someone who cares about you will care about your emotions regardless
他们会理解你的情绪是主观的。他们会理解你是在以你所能的最佳方式做出反应。他们不在乎你是否敏感。即使这样做很不方便，他们也会尊重它们。毫无疑问，如果你有问题，如果这是让你担心的事，它就应该是对他们很重要的事。我认为，当有人轻视你的情绪时，他们会让你觉得自己很傻、很尴尬。这也意味着你不太可能与其他人分享你的经历，
of how they're expressed. They will understand that your emotions are subjective. they will understand that you are reacting in the best way you can. They don't care if you're sensitive. They will respect them even if it's inconvenient. There is no question that if you have a problem, if this is something that is worrying you, it's something that should be important to them.
因为你不想让他们觉得你反应过度。这实际上是一个非常扎实的、我认为是任何形式的情感或心理虐待的主要支柱之一，那就是将你与其他人隔离开来。而在这种情况下，他们不需要在物理上孤立你。他们可以通过让你觉得其他人会有不好的反应、其他人也不会相信你，来对你进行心理上的孤立。第四种行为特征模式、
I think also when someone trivializes your emotions, they make you feel really silly and embarrassed. And what that also means is that you're unlikely to share your experiences with other people. because you don't want them to think you're overreacting. That's actually a really solid and I think one of the main pillars of any kind of emotional or psychological abuse, it's isolating you from other people. And in this instance, they don't need to physically isolate you. They can psychologically isolate you by making you feel like others are going to react unfavorably, that others aren't going to believe you either. The fourth kind of behavioral profile pattern
症状迹象是“否认”和拒绝承担责任，将其归咎于别人或他们的工作有多大压力，或者这只是一时软弱的时刻，当然，还会归咎于你，说你没有尊重他们的边界，正是因为你的错，他们才不得不那样做。这些都不是做出会进行煤气灯操纵或伤害他人的行为的有效理由，一个都没有。这可能，你知道，是部分解释，但它绝不构成道歉或彻底的借口，绝对不是。当他们以这种方式使用时，否认使他们免除了责任感，而如果没有他们承担责任，没有他们甚至承认这一点，我们就会再次觉得这是我们的错。我们才是这里的问题所在。是我们的现实需要
symptom sign is denial and a refusal to take responsibility, blaming it on someone else or how stressful their job is, or that it was just a moment of weakness, and of course, blaming it on you, saying that you're not respecting their boundaries, that this is your fault that they have to act that way. None of those are valid reasons to behave in a way that gas lights or hurts someone. none of them. That, you know, is part of the explanation, maybe, but it does not constitute an apology or an outright excuse, not in the slightest. Denial when they use it this way absolves them of a sense of responsibility and without them taking responsibility, without them even acknowledging it, we once again feel like it's our fault. We are the problem here. It's our reality that needs to be
受到质疑。是我们的想法和经历错了。第五种是转移。使用这种技术，他们会试图回避和转移对话的方向。例如，假设你走近某人并说：“我看出你一直在暗中削弱我的情绪，你让我质疑我的现实。这是煤气灯操纵。我要离开你。”可能比这稍微微妙一点，但你大概能明白这个画面。他们可能会说：“哦，你想谈论煤气灯操纵？那好吧，前几天你做X或Y的时候呢？或者你做这个的时候伤害了我的情感，怎么说？”这就是转移。这是烟幕弹，试图把内疚和责备推回到你身上，同时也寻找方法不让你说出自己的想法，不让你与他们对质，
question. It's our thoughts and our experiences that are wrong. The fifth is diverting. And using this technique, they will attempt to avoid and reroute the conversation. For example, say you approach someone and you say, I can see that you've been undermining my emotions and you're making me question my reality. That's gaslighting. I'm leaving you. Probably something a bit more nuanced than that, but you kind of get the picture. They might say, oh, you want to talk about gas sliding, well, what about the other day when you did X or Y or you hurt my feelings when you did this? That is diverting. It's smoke and mirrors trying to put the guilt and the blame back on you, but also finding ways to not allow you to say your peace, not allow you to confront them,
不给你澄清现实的机会。再一次，他们掌控着一切。他们希望你感到内疚，而不是让他们自己承担责任。最后，我们有刻板印象。现在，这不是一个我们通常会想到的方面，但我们之前在讨论操纵性别刻板印象以让女性感到歇斯底里时谈到过它，但它的内涵远不止于此。研究一再表明，虐待者如何利用基于性别、种族、性取向或国籍的刻板印象来对他们及其周围的人进行煤气灯操纵。例如，如果我们的法律系统、司法系统或整个社会已经
not give you the opportunity to clarify your reality. Once again, they are in control. They want you to feel guilt rather than having to take responsibility for it themselves. And finally, we have stereotyping. Now, this is not one that I think we typically think of, but we spoke about it before in regards to the manipulation of gender stereotyping to make women feel hysterical, but it goes a lot deeper than that. Studies have repeatedly shown how abuses can use stereotypes about people based on gender, based on race, based on sexuality or nationality, to gaslight them and those around them. For example, if our legal system or our justice system or our society in general already
对某人进行了刻板印象化，并根据某种不真实的群体特征将其视为不可信的、过度反应的或说谎者，施暴者就会知道这一点，并且他们会加以利用。当有人试图发声时，情况尤其如此。我们一次又一次地看到这一点。一个女性、一个有色人种或酷儿社群的成员站出来，突然出现了所有这些羞辱受害者的文章，或者因为他们的身份而不是因为另一个人所做的事情，将他们描绘成某种特定的形象。
stereotypes someone and sees them as untrustworthy or overreactive or as a liar based on some group characteristic that is untrue, the abuser knows that and they will leverage that. And that's especially the case when someone tries to speak out. We see this time and time again. A woman or a person of color or a member of the queer community comes forward and suddenly there are all these articles victim shaming them or painting them in a certain light because of their identity, not because of what this other person has done.
我认为有时我们未能认识到这一点——不是未能认识到，我不认为是我们的错，但我认为施暴者和进行煤气灯操纵的人利用了这样一个事实：他们了解我们的社会。他们理解刻板印象，并且他们理解社会和文化压力如何能让我们保持沉默。这也表明了煤气灯操纵不仅发生在关系语境中，它还受到群体思维和内群体设置的助长，在这种设置中，我们社会中关于特定群体的强大叙事开始说服我们，也许这个人是对的。也许我们错了。也许我们就是这种人。
And I think sometimes we fail to recognize that, not fail to recognize, I don't think it's our fault, but I think abuses and people who gaslight take advantage of the fact that they know our society. They understand stereotypes and they understand how social and cultural pressure can keep us quiet. I think it also demonstrates how gaslighting doesn't just occur in a relational context, but it's also aided by groupthink. and in-group settings whereby our society or powerful narratives around certain groups begin to convince us that maybe this person is right. Maybe we are wrong. Maybe we are this kind of person.
也许我们无法信任自己。所有这些实践、所有这些技术、更广泛的语境，它们都是协同作用的。施暴者利用了所有这一切。煤气灯操纵者利用了这一切来营造这样一种环境：你觉得自己永远不会被相信，你甚至无法相信自己或弄清你的现实，你觉得自己是错的，因为某人一直在坚定不移地让你确信你甚至无法相信自己。而这所带来的心理影响是极其深远的，也是极具破坏性的。那种持续的自我怀疑和困惑，那种内疚感，
Maybe we cannot trust ourselves. All of these practices, all of these techniques, the broader context, they work in tandem. The abuser takes advantage of all of them. The gasider takes advantage of all of them to create an environment where you feel like you'll never be believed, that you can't even believe yourself or figure out your reality, that you are in the wrong, because someone has kind of consistently convinced you that you can't even believe yourself. And the psychological impacts of that are incredibly profound and incredibly detrimental. That constant self-doubt and confusion, that sense of blame,
真的会导致大量的焦虑甚至孤立，因为你不再真正地相信自己对现实的看法，而且你觉得在人前表现出某种行为会感到尴尬，你确信自己可能快疯了，或者你无法对发生的事件做出恰当的反应。你记不清事情到底是怎么发生的了。在某些情况下，它甚至会导致创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。所以不久前曾有一项研究探讨了机构性煤气灯操纵。即发生在某种工作场所中的煤气灯操纵。他们特别关注了医疗界。他们关注了医院。他们发现被雇主进行煤气灯操纵的护士和医务人员在之后的几个月甚至几年里，经常会经历创伤后应激障碍的症状。
can really lead to a lot of anxiety and even isolation because you no longer really really trust your own version of reality and you feel embarrassed to maybe behave a certain way in front of people, you're convinced that maybe you're going crazy or that you can't appropriately respond to things that have happened. You can't remember how things actually occur. It can also, in some instances, lead to PTSD. So there was a study conducted a while ago looking at institutional gas sliding. So gaslighting that occurs in kind of like a workplace. And they specifically looked at the medical community. They looked at hospitals. And they found that nurses and medical staff who had been gaslit by employers often experienced symptoms of PTSD for months, even years after they'd
确实会导致很多焦虑甚至孤立，因为你不再真正信任自己对现实的认知，而且你可能会为自己在人前表现出某种行为感到尴尬，你确信自己可能疯了，或者你无法对发生的事情做出恰当的反应。你记不清事情到底是如何发生的。在某些情况下，它还会导致创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。因此，不久前曾进行过一项研究，探讨体制性气相滑行（注：应为气灯效应/精神控制）。也就是发生在工作场所那种精神控制。他们特别关注了医疗界。他们考察了医院。他们发现，遭到雇主精神控制的护士和医务人员，在事件发生后的数月甚至数年里，经常经历创伤后应激障碍的症状
actually left that workplace, after they'd left that position. And in severe cases, we can see things like codependency or even a version of Stockholm syndrome kind of arise. And in this instance, Stockholm syndrome is where we develop a psychological bond and a dependency on the person who is actually manipulating us. This person, this gaslighter, has created a psychological environment whereby you rely on them to affirm your reality and to tell you what emotions are appropriate and real. and therefore they know that you'll come to rely on them because they have broken down your trust in yourself. Obviously, this is in very severe cases. I will say that. But I think exposure to this pattern of behaviour can leave us with a lot of trauma that can't be discredited. So what I want to explore next is
其实在他们离开那个职位、离开那个职场之后依然会受其影响。在严重的情况下，我们甚至会看到共生关系，甚至是某种斯德哥尔摩综合征的苗头出现。在这种情况下，斯德哥尔摩综合征表现为我们对那个实际上在操纵我们的人产生了心理上的依恋和依赖。这个人，这个实施精神控制（gaslighter）的人，创造了一种心理环境，让你不得不依靠他们来肯定你的现实，依靠他们来告诉你哪些情绪才是合适和真实的。
why. Why would someone that we love, someone that we trust, whether that's a partner, a family member, whoever, why do they engage in this kind of habitual pattern of behavior? I really want to explore that, but also further to that, how to detach from these kinds of people and identify signs early on, all of that, and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more,
因此他们知道你会开始依赖他们，因为他们已经摧毁了你对自己的信任。当然，这是在非常严重的情况下，我得说明这一点。但我认为，暴露在这种行为模式中会给我们留下大量无法被忽视的心灵创伤。所以我接下来想探讨的是，为什么。为什么我们爱的人、我们信任的人，无论是伴侣、家庭成员还是其他任何人，他们会陷入这种习惯性的行为模式？我真的很想探讨这个问题，不仅如此，还要探讨如何摆脱这类人以及如何在早期识别迹象，所有这些以及更多精彩内容，就在这段简短的广告之后。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客“2%”中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，
to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
带大家看穿主导健康产业的那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经真的相信种子油天生就会引发炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
收听“2%”。也就是数字 2%。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 颁奖典礼上拍打莉尔·金（Lil' Kim）胸部的场景吗？或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush I gotta do a little kill. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack.
乔治·布什跟莉尔·金到底有什么关系。好吧，你可以在“Look Back at it”播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段时光的。其中包括最近的一集，马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）大谈 80 年代的快克（crack）毒品。说实话，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我随时都可以聊聊当年的快克，不过就是想让你们知道。我是说，马克，到了这个时候，这已经是我们第二集讨论快克了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条主线了。我们现在甚至把艾滋病也摆上台面了。谢谢你把话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听“Look Back at it”。欢迎收听我的新播客《硬核领悟》（Learn the Hard Way），我是主持人、也是你们最喜爱的治疗师吉尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。正值心理健康意识月之际，我将结合我在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的有。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross.
有时，当我们极力追求某样东西时，我们会在追逐的过程中深陷其中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却依然在追逐。我们甚至不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。
Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person? because you're afraid. Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要。你是个好人吗？因为你感到害怕。因为这完全是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。而且这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
加入我的新播客《硬核领悟》（Learn the Hard Way），我是吉尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines），我们将在这里就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索 Learn the Hard Way 并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed, revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会，揭露了她言辞中明显的矛盾之处。由此引发了一场历时多年的维权诉讼。你伪造了这份特定的测试两次对不对？我伪造了一次测试。这起案件动用了大批互联网侦探才得以侦破。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税都被用在了什么地方。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lesbian and Michael Naranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们发现了一种令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样遭遇的男子。格雷格·莱斯比安（Greg Lesbian）和迈克尔·纳拉尼尼（Michael Naranini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要承担后果了。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There is obviously no excuse for gas siding. Even if someone doesn't know they're doing it, whatever the origins of their behavior, even if they aren't trying to be actively malicious, they still have a responsibility to hold themselves accountable, to do the work, to figure out the why, the cause,
女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事绝不会结束。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《爱情陷阱》（Love Trapped）播客。精神控制（gaslighting）显然没有任何借口可言。即便某人在实施这种行为时自己并未察觉，无论其行为的根源是什么，即便他们并非出于恶意，他们依然有责任让自己承担后果，去付诸努力，去找出原因、根源，
the internal tendencies that unconsciously or consciously create this pattern or way of treating others. I really want to say that before we look into the psychological origins because I don't want any of these reasons to sound like excuses. I want to examine this from a very scientific perspective and look at the why. Why are some people like this and not others? How can we use this understanding to identify a potential gaslighter before they actually begin to employ these gaslighting techniques? You know, like I said, especially in a romantic context, most of the time this person isn't going to start gas-liding you from the first date. They're not going to outwardly tell you that this is what they plan to do. They're pretty smart.
找出那些无意识或有意识地导致这种模式或对待他人方式的内在倾向。在探讨其心理根源之前，我真的想先强调这一点，因为我不想让任何这些原因听起来像是借口。我想从非常科学的角度来审视这个问题，探讨“为什么”。为什么有些人会这样，而其他人不会？我们如何利用这种理解，在潜在的操控者真正开始使用这些精神控制技巧之前将他们识别出来？你知道，就像我刚才说的，特别是在恋爱关系中，大多数时候这个人不会从第一次约会就开始对你进行精神控制。他们不会直接告诉你这就是他们的计划。他们相当聪明。
Sometimes they don't even know. And they also know that they need to build that foundation of trust and slowly kind of introduce this confusion into our minds. So what comes before the gas-liding begins? What kind of person does this? Who should we be looking out for? One of the biggest determinants is personality. Personality, I think, can really be drawn on for a lot of explanations in psychology, whatever we're looking at. It's kind of a black box with all of the information for how we turn out the way that we do.
有时他们甚至自己都没有意识到。而且他们也知道，他们需要建立信任的基础，然后慢慢地将这种困惑引入我们的脑海。那么，在精神控制开始之前是什么？什么样的人会做这种事？我们应该警惕谁？最重要的决定因素之一就是个性。我认为，在心理学中，无论我们研究什么，个性确实都可以为许多解释提供依据。它有点像一个黑匣子，里面包含了我们最终长成现在这样子的所有信息。
But narcissism and gaslighting are very closely linked. And sometimes I've seen it like used interchangeably. So narcissism, it's actually a personality disorder. It's characterized by a lack of empathy, by an excessive need for admiration and a sense of superiority or entitlement over others. This behavioral profile allows someone to initiate gaslighting with a lot less guilt and also ease. If we also examine the intentions of gas sliding behavior, that is to maintain control, that's something that narcissists inherently crave.
但自恋与精神控制（gaslighting）有着非常紧密的联系。有时我看到它们甚至被混为一谈。所以，自恋其实是一种人格障碍。它的特征是缺乏同理心、对赞美有着过度需求，以及对他人表现出优越感或特权感。这种行为特征使得一个人能够以更少的内疚感和更轻松的方式发起精神控制。如果我们同时审视精神控制行为的动机，那就是为了保持控制，这是自恋者内心里极度渴望的东西。
And therefore they're often drawn to gaslighting as a way to manipulate, as a way to control, as a way to ensure their needs are the first ones being met before yours, that their version of reality is always right. And I think additionally to that, because they can't feel empathy the way that most people can, they're not going to have any guilt in doing this. They're not going to feel bad for making you feel crazy. they're not going to feel bad for lying. In the same vein, I think pathological liars are also more prone to have gas-sighting tendencies.
因此，他们经常被精神控制所吸引，把它作为一种操纵的方式、一种控制的方式、一种确保他们的需求永远先于你的需求得到满足、确保他们的现实版本永远是正确的方式。我想除此之外，由于他们无法像大多数人那样去感受同理心，他们在这样做时不会感到任何内疚。他们不会因为让你觉得自己疯了而感到不好受，他们不会因为说谎而感到内疚。同理，我认为病态说谎者也更容易产生精神控制的倾向。
One of the main reasons people lie is to avoid accountability. There's this really fascinating study on this, and it found that a lot of people who we would diagnose as compulsive or pathological liars, they report that one of the main reasons they lie when they're asked why, why do you lie? Is there a reason you do this? What they say is because at some stage, they learnt that lying can get them what they want with little consequences. It has some personal utility or value.
人们说谎的主要原因之一是为了逃避责任。有一项关于此的非常迷人的研究发现，许多被我们诊断为强迫性或病态说谎者的人报告说，当被问及原因时——为什么你撒谎？你这样做有原因吗？他们说的一个主要原因是因为在某个阶段，他们了解到说谎可以让他们付出很小的代价就能得到他们想要的东西。它具有某种个人实用性或价值。
And when lies can be used to control others, they get what they want from the people around them. In that way, I think, pathological lying and gaslighting, they very naturally kind of operate in tandem. There have been some other explanations as to why this emerges. some actually believe that all gaslighting or manipulative behavior is actually learned. So for children who grow up with parents who gaslight, their behavior becomes normalized. We also know from Bandura's experiments on social learning that children primarily learn through observations and they may not even realize what they're doing. Their parents have set up this kind of blueprint as children, the only way we can learn
当谎言可以用来控制他人时，他们就能从周围人那里得到他们想要的东西。从这个意义上说，我认为病态说谎和精神控制非常自然地会协同起作用。关于这种现象为何会出现，还有其他一些解释。有些人甚至认为所有的精神控制或操纵行为都是后天习得的。比如，在父母会实施精神控制的家庭中长大地孩子，他们的这种行为会变得正常化。我们从班杜拉（Bandura）关于社会学习的实验中也了解到，孩子主要是通过观察来学习的，他们甚至可能没有意识到自己在做什么。他们的父母为他们设定了这样的蓝图：作为孩子，我们学会生存的唯一方式，
to survive, the only way we learn what is normal is by what our caregivers are doing or what people around us are doing. On the other hand, they may also learn through trial and error, I guess, that in order to get what they want, they have to manipulate. They have to gaslight other people. Maybe that was due to a strict upbringing or emulating older siblings. That's just one of the explanations, that it is a learnt behaviour. I think manipulation can also be used for status. A lot of people call people like Putin or Donald Trump gas-liders, they use lies and create a false reality for political power. And at the very end of the spectrum of explanations, is that gas-lighting is utilised for sadistic pleasure. So there are some people out there who just like other people
我们了解什么是正常的唯一方式，就是通过观察照顾者在做什么，或者周围的人在做什么。另一方面，我想他们也可能是通过试错来学习的：为了得到自己想要的东西，他们必须进行操纵。他们必须对别人进行精神控制。也许这归咎于严格的家教，或者是模仿年长的兄弟姐妹。这只是其中一种解释，即这是一种后天习得的行为。我认为操纵也可以用来获取地位。许多人称普京或唐纳德·特朗普为精神控制者，他们利用谎言并为了政治权力制造虚假的现实。而在各种解释谱系的另一端，则是精神控制被用于满足施虐的快感。所以世上确实有些人就是喜欢看到别人
to hurt. They get pleasure from seeing others suffering. And although I think that is extremely rare, very, very rare, it does just kind of go to show how nuanced this behavior and the origins of this behavior are, how much they have to do with personality and something internally that's gone wrong, some part of our temperament, some part of other people's temperament, that just never fully developed. But looking at these exponential, nations and these origins, I hope that the one thing that is most clear is that none of them have to do with us. It is not our fault. We have not done anything to deserve to be gaslit. We're not asking for it. We don't have some personal vulnerability. Nothing about this has to do with
受到伤害。他们从看到别人受苦中获得快感。尽管我认为这种情况极其罕见，非常非常罕见，但这恰恰说明了这种行为以及这种行为的根源是多么微妙，它们与个性和内在某种出了问题的部分、与我们气质中的某些部分、与其他人气质中那些从未完全发育成熟的部分有多大关系。但看了这些种种解释和根源后，我希望最清晰的一点是：这些都与我们无关。这不是我们的错。我们没有做任何错事来罪有应得地遭受精神控制。我们不是自找的。我们并没有什么个人的脆弱性。这一切都与
personal blame. Gaslighting is entirely the gaslighter's problem from personality disorders to maybe even genetics, observational learning. None of that is something that we are responsible for. However, the question still remains, what do we do? If we've identified that we are in a situation where someone is trying to alter our reality or manipulate us for their gain, how do we detach from this person. I think firstly, talk to other people you trust about your experience. This person is betting on your unconditional trust in them and their reality and their coercive tactics. So when we begin to outsource and get advice from others who have a more objective perspective, it begins to undermine the ways that they're manipulating us. This incredible article put it this way. One of the
个人责备无关。精神控制完全是操控者自身的问题，从人格障碍到甚至基因、观察学习，这些都不是我们所需要负责的。然而，问题依然存在：我们该怎么办？如果我们已经发现自己正处于这样一种处境中：有人试图改变我们的现实，或者为了他们的利益而操纵我们，我们该如何摆脱这个人。我认为首先，和信任的其他人谈谈你的经历。这个人是在赌你对他们的无条件信任、赌你对他们的现实以及他们的强制性战术的信任。因此，当我们开始向外界寻求外援，并从那些拥有更客观视角的人那里获取建议时，就开始削弱他们操纵我们的方式。这篇精彩的文章是这样说的：精神控制者的首要
primary goals of the gas slider is psychological isolation and emotional dependence, especially if they have narcissistic personality disorder or something of the sort. So when we reach out to our support system, to share with them our reality, to tell them what is happening, what we know, what we've seen and experienced, we are further integrating our truth in our minds. We are sharing our narrative. Further to that, I would say keep track of your experiences, either in a journal or a notes app, reaffirm your truth, reaffirm the truth, as it is happening to you. So you can kind of push back against their lives and manipulation with what really happened, not just externally, but also internally. How did you respond to this?
目标之一就是心理孤立和情感依赖，特别是如果他们患有自恋型人格障碍或类似的问题。因此，当我们向支持系统求助，与他们分享我们的现实，告诉他们发生了什么、我们知道什么、我们看到了什么和经历了什么时，我们就是在内心进一步巩固了我们的真相。我们在分享自己的故事。除此之外，我想说，把你的经历记录下来，可以写在日记里或便签应用中，重申你的真相，在事情发生时重申真相。这样你就可以用真正发生的事情来回击他们的谎言和操纵，不仅在外部层面上，在内在层面上也是如此。你当时是如何反应的？
How did you feel when they made you feel that way? That doesn't mean that you need to sit down and confront them with all your evidence and get them to admit everything because I think it's highly unlikely that they will, we know that one of the biggest tactics used by people who gaslight is denial. And that determination to deny runs steep. Additionally, when we try to confront people like this and get them to accept our reality, our perspective, in some ways, we're still asking for their approval over our experiences. We don't need their approval. They don't deserve access to that. you know your reality you know what happened whether they confirm or deny whether they just dig their heels in deeper that should not change anything about what you went through or are going through
当他们让你有那种感觉时，你作何感想？这并不意味着你需要坐下来用你所有的证据去质问他们，让他们承认一切，因为我认为他们极不可能这样做。我们知道，那些实施精神控制的人最常用的策略之一就是否认。而且那种执意否认的决心根深蒂固。此外，当我们试图与这样的人对质并让他们接受我们的现实、我们的视角时，在某种程度上，我们仍然在寻求他们对我们经历的认可。我们不需要他们的认可。他们不配获得这种特权。你知道你的现实，你知道发生了什么，无论他们是承认还是否认，无论他们是更加固执己见，这都不应该改变你已经经历或正在经历的任何事情，
and what that means for you it also provides them with an opportunity to learn and change tactics to know us better and therefore get better at manipulating us i think a person who is gaslighting will blatantly lie they will shift the narrative they will minimize how you feel. So look out for those common phrases, you know, they're just being so dramatic. You're making things up that never happened. You're blowing things out of proportion. If you want to have a conversation with them, keep it super simple. You're not there to argue or convince them that your feelings matter. You know that they matter. And if they begin to deny or minimize, you have every right to leave that conversation. You know, I don't usually believe in ghosting or
以及这对你意味着什么。这也为他们提供了了解和改变战术的机会，让他们更了解我们，从而更擅长操纵我们。我认为一个实施精神控制的人会公然撒谎，他们会扭曲事实，他们会淡化你的感受。所以要注意那些常见的短语，你知道的，比如“你太戏剧化了”、“你是在凭空捏造根本没有发生过的事”、“小题大做”。如果你想和他们对话，保持超级简单。你不是去和他们争论或说服他们让你的感受显得重要。你知道它们很重要。如果他们开始否认或淡化，你完全有权离开那场谈话。你知道的，我通常不相信玩失踪或
icing someone out. But in some situations, it is called for. And if you need to distance yourself, they don't need an explanation from you. You have every right to set your boundaries and do what's best for yourself. They've been doing what's best for them all along. So you are very much in your right to do that as well by distancing yourself, by putting the issue to bed, by really being like I'm going to focus on how I can move forward. And if that doesn't include you, that you, that's your loss. That's your loss. I also think be gentle with yourself in the aftermath and notice when you start to engage in negative self-talk or self-blame.
把人晾在一边（icing someone out）。但在某些情况下，这是有必要的。如果你需要拉开距离，你不需要向他们解释。你完全有权划清界限，做对你自己最好的事。他们可是一直都在做对自己最好的事。所以你通过拉开距离、将问题搁置、真正下定决心专注于如何向前迈进，来做对自己最好的事，这是完全合情合理的。如果这段前行之路不包含你，那是你的损失。那是你的损失。我也认为，在事后要对自己温柔一点，并注意自己何时开始陷入负面自我对话或自我责备。
It's fairly common, I would say, to still feel some of the remnants of their actions and its impact on you to sometimes question your reality because we have been conditioned or indoctrinated by this person's actions. We may also experience what we would call an emotional hangover. which is kind of that energetic residue left over from a particularly traumatic or intense interaction or event. I promise you, you did the best you could, you're a good person, a trusting person, you are kind, you are forgiving. These are beautiful qualities that you do not have to erase just because of someone else. Finally, professional help is so, so important here. There is nothing I could ever say on this podcast. and that is going to help as much as a therapist or a psychologist could.
我想，在经历了他们的行为及其对你的影响后，依然感受到一些余波，甚至有时会质疑现实，这其实挺常见的，因为我们已经被这个人的行为进行了长期的条件反射或洗脑。我们可能还会经历我们所说的“情绪宿醉”，这是一种由特别具创伤性或强烈的互动、事件所残留的能量残余。我向你们保证，你们已经尽力了，你们是好人，是信任他人的人，你们是善良的、宽容的。这些都是美好的品质，你不需要仅仅因为别人的原因就将它们抹去。最后，专业的帮助在这里非常非常重要。我在这个播客里所说的一切，
Someone who knows you personally, who you can go to in confidence, who has to kind of give you an objective opinion and specific skills. You know, they've seen it before. They can speak to you and speak you through exactly what needs to be done based on your situation. I think it's a complicated thing. it's a very nuanced, a nuanced experience for sure. But having the proper understanding and the proper skills and the proper language around what it is can really help us overcome it and really help us identify that it's not our fault.
都永远比不上心理治疗师或心理学家所能提供的帮助。一个真正了解你个人、你可以向其倾诉并能保守秘密的人，能够为你提供客观的意见和具体的技能。你知道的，他们以前见识过。他们可以根据你的情况与你沟通，并一步步指导你具体该做些什么。我认为这是一件复杂的事情。这绝对是一种非常微妙、细致的体验。但拥有对这种现象的正确理解、正确的技能以及正确的语言，确实能帮助我们克服它，并真正帮助我们认清这不是我们的错。
It's really not our fault. It's someone else's intentions, someone else's problematic behavior that they need to figure out. They need to work through that. They need to go back to their childhood or go back to their roots or really go back to their personality and examine what kind of issue is this really stemming from? What kind of vulnerability or insecurity or problematic behavior am I masking by doing this to someone else? So I really hope that this episode helped you out. Hope it gave you some further information and some kind of better evidence-based understanding
这真的不是我们的错。这是别人的动机，是别人需要去搞清楚的有问题行为。他们需要去解决这个问题。他们需要回到自己的童年，回到他们的根源，或者真正回到他们的个性中去审视：这种问题究竟根源于什么？通过对别人做这种事，我到底在掩盖什么样的脆弱、不安或有问题的行为？所以我真的希望这一集对你们有所帮助。希望它能为你提供更多的信息，以及对这个词更好的、基于证据的理解。
of what this term means. I see it used so often on social media platforms and I think if that's the only place that you receive psycho education, sometimes our interpretation can become quite ambiguous and not specific enough. So if there's someone in your life who needs to hear this episode, please feel free to share it along. I really think it is an important topic. It's something we all need to be cognizant of and aware of and be able to use as part of part of our language and our kind of psychological toolkit. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts,
我看到这个词在社交媒体平台上被如此频繁地使用，我想如果那是你接受心理教育的唯一途径，有时我们的理解可能会变得相当含糊，不够具体。所以如果你生命中有谁需要听到这一集，请随时转发分享。我真的认为这是一个重要的话题。这是我们所有人都需要认识到、意识到，并能够将其作为我们的语言和某种心理工具箱一部分的话题。一如既往，如果你喜欢这一集，请随时在 Apple Podcasts、
Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. And if you want to support the show, if you want to support me, please do check out our Patreon. It is attached in the episode description. It's really quite ridiculously cheap. It's like a dollar a month. It's like the cheapest version. and every kind of small bit of support really does go a long way.
Spotify 或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。如果你想支持这个节目，如果你想支持我，请务必查看我们的 Patreon。它就附在节目简介中。真的非常便宜，简直荒谬。就像每月一美元。这是最便宜的版本，
I really appreciate all of you who have already decided to join along in that community. So thank you so much. And as always, we will be back next week with another episode. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit are armored.
每一份小小的支持都真的意义重大。我非常感谢所有已经决定加入这个社区的你们，非常感谢。一如既往，我们下周将带着新的一集回归。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《硬核领悟》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人吉尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都无法坦诚交流的真实对话，但在这里，你是在和一位深谙此道的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人把西装当作盔甲。
It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%.
它向世界释放的信号是：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《硬核领悟》。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客“2%”中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
我剖析了精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听“2%”。也就是 TWA%（数字2%）。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。当一群女性发现她们约会的竟然是同一个劣迹斑斑的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.
我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。在“Look Back at it”播客中。从 1979 年开始，那对我来说是个大时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段时光的。与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊 80 年代。那是一个疯狂的年代。那是一个疯狂的年代。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何平台上收听“Look Back at it”。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。品质保证。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。